good morning Oscar Karen's fakin when
Karen Hobbs was just 24 she was
diagnosed with cervical cancer it was
caught early and the tumor was
successfully removed have you been
invited for a screening are you 25 or
about to be 25 now she uses her
experience to encourage others to go for
screening or to guide them through their
treatment by answering calls at a
charity helpline but a new test will
eventually mean women won't necessarily
need a smear test at all which so many
dread instead providing a sample from
home people don't go for loads of
different reasons I want people to be
tested so if it means doing an at-home
test as long as the test is effective it
means they're more comfortable they
don't have to have anything inserted
into their vagina a stranger's not doing
it if that means that they will get
screened that's amazing the current
screening process works by taking a
sample of cells from the cervix at a
doctors surgery but under the new test a
urine or vaginal sample is taken using a
DIY home kits several studies have shown
the results to be just as accurate as
from the clinically taken sample
scientists at Queen Mary University of
London asked 600 women to provide
samples collected themselves using a
simple swab I think there's enough
evidence for to begin to use it now for
women who do not come for a clinician
taken sample this is clearly a as good a
test and can be done at home in the
future we think that this can
potentially be done in all women but
there is more work to be done to look
exactly how it compares to the
clinically taken samples the new s5
tests can identify the most dangerous
types of the human papilloma virus and
then indicate the risk of getting cancer
around a quarter of women currently
failed to go for cervical screening when
invited is hope the new home testing kit
will not only improve take-up but also
save the NHS money do women die every
day from cervical cancer even with
campaigns like this in the number of
women going for tests
just keeps falling at any one time there
are about five million women who are
overdue they're screening tests at the
moment so we're a 21 year low of women
attending for screening so we really
need to change the story on that and
that's where anything which makes that
test easier and more accessible for all
is really really welcome the new test
has been described as a game-changer
there seems little doubt it'll mean more
lives are saved
Emma virtually Sky News